did y'all catch up on Last of Us yes
yeah [__] amazing did you actually
watch it oh Alex did you actually
watching it's crazy that like all you
got to do is watch a show I know bro I
know I know I know I don't know
I know no no no stop saying I know I
know please get yelled at I should watch
it I should watch it you can watch so
much other [__] you watch eight hours of
a guy who could hold his breath a lot
you can't just watch a [__] 50-minute
TV show yeah I know I need to the issue
is I know I have to watch it with my
girl and she said oh it's too sad to see
the gay guys die but then keep watching
but then I gotta watch her alone I gotta
find alone time I can't do that all
right anyway
thank you listen uh this is one of those
this is this is one episode that if you
played a video game
it ruins the episode really because I
[__] loved it everybody who saw this
episode is pretty good I thought
everybody who saw this episode has told
me this is the best episode of the show
it might be and I thought maybe I was
tripping because I didn't get anything
hey [__] come on bro
it was different this [__] was fire but
that was like that was like an outlier
amazing episode it's almost like a movie
this was my favorite that one could be
better let's say that but I think this
is my favorite episode listen nobody's
not gonna either take everybody I've
spoke to that hasn't played the game has
said this episode was unfucking
believable and it was unfucking
believable but because I knew every part
of it the thing about this episode is
think about it there's so many surprises
That You Don't See coming yes okay the
fact that they're eating people [__]
you don't really never saw that coming
you know something spooky is going on
but you don't see it coming right yeah
and then if you look back on the episode
and you go oh [__] that's why shorty
wanted her father buried immediately
yeah oh remember
can we bury him right now and he goes
I bury him now because the ground is too
cold we'll bury him in the Sprint [__]
you didn't know that she knew of course
everybody knows that's why there's that
uneasiness
[Laughter]
give me two he's like two more yeah
I'm so dumb even when they brought in
when they said it was venison but
looking back it was clearly human meat
I'm like oh that's from the thing they
just killed like the first time
throughout him pick up on it at all yeah
yeah I didn't do yeah so so that's the
girl like everybody there there's this
uneasiness that I think that really
captured is is they're [__] brilliant
like capturing
in Emotion without words is kind of
tricky like just the way they were
eating you knew they were eating
something [__] up
just the way they would film the bowls
like there'd be like these Zoom ins on
the bowls and like scraping you heard
the sounds of like the spoons
what I picked up was uh yo we're so
hungry because you have like some people
are just like other people's trying to
savor it or whatever the case is like
that's how what I think about that one
dude
takes the tiniest bite and then puts it
in his mouth
the guy who is like the right-hand man
of the redhead remember he took the
chair almost struggled Oh I thought he
was Savory he knows because he's one of
the guys that is chopping up the box
yeah yeah I knew he knew that guy is
actually the voice actor for Joel in the
video game yeah so it's really cool to
see him in it right nerd yeah
that's the second one I saw the whole
episode I even watched it like behind
the scenes thing yep and I knew I forgot
he was in the video I didn't know what
character he was but he did say he was
in the video don't have been gaming your
girls she was like I beat Harry Potter
yeah Emma beat Harry Potter she'd be
Hogwarts and then that day I was like I
can't let you have the whole day I had
to beat Last of Us yeah y'all are
putting work bro putting in work the
whole day I was just in the house and
last of us too
we'll get to last of us too and why it's
the greatest video game ever in a second
that [__] was getting hard I put that
[__] on very easy I switched up Midway
because I was like I don't need to be
killing zombies I need to figure out
what happened to this [__] oh my God
yeah
okay but back to the episode so the
episode captures these [__] emotions
it's awesome to finally see her take
care of Joel yeah we never get to see
her be the caregiver yeah and then
what's really cool is you see the
humanity come out right because that's
kind of what Humanity's about it's just
about us taking care of one another and
that's what we have to do and you're not
always going to be the protector you're
not always going to be a provider
there's gonna be someone else who might
be protecting providing you in some
certain ways and it's really cool to see
them Pond but
um it's really cool to see what
types of groups pop up in an apocalyptic
situation one of those being the
flesh-eating cult religious religious
yeah and like he even called himself
that it was very self-aware yeah she was
like is this a cult and he's like he's
like I mean I guess we're kind of that
but it's just traditional bible stuff no
yeah like it was it was cool for him to
be like self-aware of what Cults are
yeah no cult leader thinks they're a
cult leader which when you don't know so
much of the stuff you picked up on
because you knew like the way they're
eating which is cool I like uh at the
time I was like oh he's just a regular
guy that maybe he's like a good guy when
I saw that line I was like oh he's a
good guy because he's got some
self-awareness to it so I never saw the
heel turn coming because I was like oh
he's so when you see the heel turn
I don't even think I saw a tell really
uh until he locks her up until he wants
to [__] her oh when he puts his hand
then for sure but even then when he's
like when he slaps the girl you're like
oh this guy's [__] off yeah there's
still your father or something like that
was crazy
yeah
the entire episode you think he's like a
good guy yeah I love that in the
beginning though as you reflect can we
bury him right now yeah
and I didn't even think so then she
gotta eat them
she gotta eat her dad and she knows is
her dad only two or three people in the
community or whatever the [__] know that
they're either chopping up people yeah
but they know they're chopping up but I
think you get sick if you eat humans
cap is that true yeah that's what they
say I I'm pretty sure you get sick if
you eat human I think there is some sort
of like uh evolutionary evolutionary
advantage that we have because
apparently we're not very tasty like a
lot of times in like shark attacks
they'll bite the humans and then let go
because our meat doesn't taste good and
the animals in the jungle apparently
don't like the way that we taste like
we're not apparently that good tasting
and that's a huge Advantage yeah right
like when you think about it compared to
tuna think about raw tuna how good it is
why would God bro that's amazing that
makes you think of evolution as [__]
why would an animal evolve to be this
delicious piece of tuna the fat part
in your life with nothing done to it and
even the worst part of it fire with some
spicy man
it is bad that's the thing that's the
thing where you got to start thinking
about Evolution you're like chickens no
reason they should be that good yeah
cows no reasons I know he's gonna do
something to it a shark a shark is
eating fat belly tuna thousand dollars a
bite yes
a shark is eating thousands of dollars
just for like two days for no reason all
they could do is just be with the homies
and hopefully this the shark is like Ah
that's too many yeah but why would they
say it's too many just start biting this
whole food that's a feast hundreds of
thousands Thanksgiving bruh yeah and
that's just regular moot yeah you can
stop getting us to talk about [__] that
you know about um
lately oh yeah all right guys we're
gonna take a break for a second because
it's March [__] Madness and
flagrant is getting down with this
bracket syndrome and we're doing it with
run your pool okay you go to
play.runyourpool.com flagrant right now
you join the brackets we got free money
if you win look at that run your pools
give enough 1500 okay divide by the top
five winners it's free for you to sign
up you just go sign up right now you can
win 1500. we're in it Akash in it Market
Alex and it miles and it does in it I'm
in it Jamil's in it it's going down okay
play dot runyourpool.com flagrant right
now you could win that free money
and to make it even more sweet
the winner
we gonna double up that [__] oh [__]
we go double up that [__] money
whoever wins the bracket we're doubling
up out of our part okay
that's you you go to
play.runyourpool.com flagrant sign up
right now let's get into this March
Madness action okay it's another Pool it
costs you absolutely nothing and you can
win real bread now let's get back to the
show yeah I thought I thought this was
just a you know it's a phenomenal
episode absolutely but there was part of
me that wishes I didn't know where was
going because if you think about the
episode every new reveal
there's a bunch of reveals here yeah
right that make okay oh wow he's
actually an [__] he's not good oh
[__] he wants to have sex with a
teenager oh [__] he's a crazy cult
leader oh [__] they're eating humans
yeah like there's oh [__] Joel actually
got up and he's able to fight them off
there were like five different uh
misdirections that I all knew yeah so
while it was incredible for the people
who didn't play the game yeah I imagine
the people who did play the game was
like this executed really well it felt
like the game yeah freakishly similar
but just as a gamer though I'm a gamer
yeah did you have the control in your
hand while you were watching dude I do
that while you're watching it you're
kind of I do that 100 I do that like
when Ellie was like chopping in there I
was like oh right stick
here's a question that moment yeah when
you find out that uh Joel killed their
friend their friend their friend like
their friend their friend oh yeah yeah
crazy person tried to kill and he was
with a little girl yeah do you think
they were trying to kill because they
tried to kill Joel do you think they
were trying to kill him to eat them no I
think they were probably looking for
like supplies or food food I think that
if they did kill them they would have
taken them back because they are eating
people right but I don't think that was
like the goal because but do you know
they're referencing no it's it you do
know remember the uh well no horse
remember when Joel gets stabbed yeah
yeah okay so but that's what I'm saying
because that guy went up to Joel and
attacked him Joel was leaving yeah so
for me it's like why are you why are you
just attacking this yeah it would
definitely probably be I think my
thinking was maybe they were attacking
him to eat him yeah yeah 100 yeah 100
yeah it's just [__] phenomenal that's
a weird-ass Community though because if
you know they eat humans and then it's
like [__] if we don't kill any animal
anyone's next yeah yes yeah what's the
process for that
newest person maybe this is crazy for me
I'm like I get it you're gonna starve to
death people will do things to survive
yeah also there's truly tapped into a
resort so what they're decided to make
in a resort Community it's brilliant
it's already caged off there's an end to
it right you can protect it easily it
has all the different things as the big
meeting room has different cabins for
all the different people it's on a
[__] Lake yeah Al laughing at me to
rest the way he's dressed I'm loving it
first of all this is kid super you got a
problem with it
[Laughter]
[Music]
every once in a while if you put your
clothes on the right person you missed
I was laughing at Mark because Mark has
really been mad
you're so good at explaining stuff and
I'm like wow I feel like I saw it yeah
you felt like I was talking about the
Bibles yeah yeah you think he's an idiot
are you saying that he's dead you're
saying he's bad at explaining
you're a sucker
he knows how to just you're the hottest
girl you can feel good for one moment
can I give some confidence
[Applause]
gonna say I'm a bully I gotta build him
up exactly
I didn't eat that he literally said yeah
you got a good point yeah
talk about my [__] pants
[Music]
a funny comedian name is column Tyrell I
go Colin can I ask you a question is
your real name calm c-o-l M he goes yes
that's how we spell it in Ireland but
here people don't get it so I just added
column I added you right exactly
c-o-l-u-m yeah
[Music]
yeah okay
Last of Us excitement about the final
episode very very exciting and the
ending I got emotional watching
the ending where he calls her baby girl
that like that's officially like his
daughter now yeah that was like I got
emotional that [__] hit my wife yeah I
didn't pick that one up wasn't in the
game
no but that's a good ass point because I
well you could also point it out it's
gonna come full circle right now he's
like not at the beginning of the show
he's not allowing himself to love anyone
the way he loved his daughter and then
when she's all horrified she [__]
kills it as an actor yeah this girl is
amazing she's a monster dude incredible
but then she's like super emotional
super [__] traumatized and he just
like puts his hands on her face he's
like baby girl T it's me it's okay I was
like God damn it's like now he got he's
officially like a father again and he
saved her the way he couldn't save his
last girl this is the craziest [__] I
ever I ever experienced at a video game
I'm being dead ass about this 100
I'm being 100
play as
as you explore both of their stories as
this at the same time oh [__] you start
to fall in love and root for them and
then you gotta kill each other
multiple times and while you're doing it
you don't really want to kill that
person that you were playing as for
hours and you kind of root for it's
ballsy to do in a storytelling
perspective especially for a video game
because you gotta get someone to fall in
love with it's imagine like they really
got to fall in love with Thanos remember
like they kind of got us like
rationalize with him but they didn't go
through imagine they went through times
where Thanos really helped someone and
save someone and raise someone like
cared about something Etc now you really
[__] with this dude you don't want these
other guys to kill him well that's what
he did with that one girl that he threw
off the [__] thing 100 but imagine
that whole thing was explored for a
whole movie by itself and I remember
going through this game and I'm playing
this game I'm like oh these
[__] are nice now there's way
more like throwing out Progressive [__]
in it like there's a trans kid in it
there's like the lesbian love story and
randomly they just like enter a
synagogue and they talk about like what
the Jews have went through it's actually
hilarious because it's like you're in
the middle of a global endemic right
like yeah endemic is where it's done
yeah I think so like everybody's died
but there's still a moment where the
Jewish girl is like but you don't know
what the Jews have been there
it's the most hilarious in the game like
like yeah we understand everybody's dad
and there's like a thing that turns
people into mushrooms and they just eat
people but
so I get why there was like this like
super like Q Anon outrage about the game
because there was a lot of outrage about
two where like the super right wing
people were like dude Progressive agenda
because they hit on all the Beats yeah
dudes trans kids in case yeah and it
feels stuffed in that being said the
idea of like playing as your villain and
like making your villain's story become
like very reasonable and rational and
like crazy yeah like circumstance create
their lives and like what they believe
that you play as the girl the whole time
well there's multiple girls that you
play as oh you play as the girl and you
play as the girl the girl's going after
and then you start playing as her who's
the girl the girl's going after uh I
guess I'll tell it don't really ruin
that much I kind of ruins okay you want
me to ruin it nah anyway your place the
girl and the girl the girl's going after
okay and that ties into what happens in
the next episode that you guys will see
that's crazy but it's really [__]
with every video again
what did Bowser go through that's what
we need to do yeah maybe he's not that
bad maybe he's not that bad maybe
a good guy bro what did he have to do
that exactly
he tried to save someone else maybe you
know hey we don't know what these
Italian [__] are maybe he was
taking him back yeah maybe it was his
ancestors Italian [__] could be
on some Cuomo [__] trying to rape up the
princess and he's like yo let me protect
you
exactly yeah I'm a dragon and also a
turtle that's difficult for me to
process think about it think about what
animal even is Bowser identifier
him and turtle up no yes you got Spikes
all over his shells
yeah you understand what his life is now
you people he's taken care of you think
about what he had to do to earn the
respect of those little pumbas or
whatever
you're dressed as right now
okay and he was just taking care of them
Goombas little [__] dollops yes
they ride for him
[Music]
Turtles exactly yeah when you really
think about it there's only two human
beings going after that princess yeah
that one guy and then his brother who
jumps really tall and then everybody
else is really rocking with Bowser where
the humans looking after the princess
they're all like go past yeah she wasn't
worth looking at maybe maybe that [__]
maybe yeah you know what I'm saying
exactly a hard [__] oh you got me oh
but you got a problem with Chris Rock
does it huh oh okay
boys
[Laughter]